qui c'est marrant
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre ce matin sur
notre antenne la lecture des conclusions
de la commission mixte paritaire sur les
deux projets de loi qui crée le
défenseur des droits le défenseur des
droits va regrouper quatre autorités
jusqu'à présent indépendantes le
médiateur de la république le défenseur
des enfants la commission nationale de
déontologie de la sécurité et la halde
comme en foot et les sénateurs le
contrôleur général des prisons va
conserver son autonomie
ce défenseur des droits sera assisté
d'adjoints et de collèges les
différences d'appréciation entre députés
et sénateurs portait d'ailleurs sur les
pouvoirs de ses adjoints et de ses
collèges finalement il a été prévu que
le défenseur des droits consulterait à
les collèges et les adjoints sur toute
nouvelle question
voilà tout de suite donc direction
l'hémicycle très bonne matinée à tous
l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen des
conclusions des commissions mixtes
paritaires chargés d'élaborer un texte
sur les dispositions restant en
discussion des projets de loi organique
et ordinaire relatifs au défenseur des
droits est dans la discussion générale
commune
la parole est à monsieur patrice gélard
rapporteur pour le sénat
des commissions mixtes paritaires
vous avez la parole patrice gélard
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des sceaux mes chers collègues nous
avons examiné aujourd'hui en troisième
lecture en fête
les conclusions des deux commissions
mixtes paritaires portant sur la loi
organique et sur la loi ordinaire
concernant le défenseur des droits je
dois dire que ce qui concerne le
défenseur des droits le garde des sceaux
doit se féliciter du travail tout à fait
remarquable accompli par le sénat
en effet le texte initial que nous
avions reçues de la part du gouvernement
étaient incomplets insatisfaisant et
difficile à faire fonctionner faute de
précision suffisante
nous avions été amenées à compléter ce
texte en y incluant la halde et en
développant un certain nombre de
mécanismes internes du futur défenseur
des droits
notamment les adjoints qui n'était pas
prévue dans le texte initial du
gouvernement et les collèges qui n'était
pas non plus prévu ce qui nous animait à
l'époque lorsque nous avons examiné en
première lecture le texte sur le
défenseur des droits c'était deux choses
c'était faire en sorte que les
attributions nouvelles du défenseur des
droits ne soient pas moindres que celles
des autorités administratives
indépendantes auquel il se substituait
et puis d'autre part il fallait faire en
sorte que le défenseur des droits ne
devienne pas un dictateur des droits
c'est-à-dire soit seul à décider
il va avoir tellement de fonction à
remplir qu'il était nécessaire qu'il
soit assisté
d'où la création des adjoints et d'où la
création des collègues
et bien cette attitude qui était la
nôtre a été très largement reprise par
l'assemblée nationale dès que celle-ci
est examiné le texte en première lecture
néanmoins un certain nombre de choses
subsistaient et qui ont pu être gommés
ou régler lors de la deuxième lecture
tente assemblée nationale qu'au sénat
ainsi nous avons plus maintenir un
certain nombre de points de vue qui
était le nôtre dès le départ notamment
le fait que le contrôleur général des
lieux de dette de détention soit en
dehors d'eux
du statut du défenseur des droits en ce
qui concerne le champ des compétences du
défenseur des droits l'assemblée
nationale nous a suivis dans ce domaine
de la halde par exemple est également en
ce qui concerne du moins au niveau de la
seconde lecture
lorsque l'assemblée nationale n'a pas
retenu les actions collectives et n'a
pas retenu non plus les conflits qui
pourraient surgir entre personnes
morales de droit public quelques points
de désaccord subsistent est néanmoins à
l'issue des deux lectures de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat
le premier point de désaccord portait
sur la composition des collèges en effet
l'assemblée nationale avait prévu que
deux des membres des collèges rappelle
que les collèges ces neuf personnes que
deux des membres des collèges été nommé
par le défenseur des droits
cette nomination par le défenseur des
droits vous tissez en fin de compte à
cloner le défenseur des droits et à
faire en sorte que au lieu d'avoir une
voix au sein du collège de neuf
personnes
il en dispose est de 3 c'est la raison
pour laquelle et l'assemblée nationale
se ralliaient notre point de vue sur
cette question
nous avons souhaité que le défenseur des
droits ne nomme pas des personnalités
qualifiées
mais que ces personnalités qualifiées
soit nommé d'une part par le président
de l'assemblée nationale
d'autre part par le président du sénat
donc pour deux des collèges
le président de l'assemblée nationale et
le président du sénat donneront
donneront chacun trois personnes et pour
un autre collège sera deux personnes
nommé par le président de chacune des
deux assemblées
deuxième point de désaccord qui
subsistaient entre l'assemblée nationale
et nous c'était le problème de la
consultation des collèges là notre point
de vue était clair il s'agissait de
faire en sorte que les collèges n'est
pas moins de pouvoirs que ce qu'ils
avaient dans la période précédente
lorsque ces collèges existait pour du
moins la cnds et la halde
un problème se pose effectivement pour
le d
défenseur des enfants il n'y avait pas
de collège pour le défenseur des enfants
ne l'avons créée et donc on pouvait pas
suivre ce qui existait auparavant
le texte que les avions adopté prévoyait
que le défenseur des droits
consult c'était à présent de l'indicatif
et je rappelle qu'en droit le présent de
l'indicatif vos impératifs l'assemblée
nationale avait remplacé ce présent de
l'indicatif par peut consulter et la
commission mixte paritaire s'est rallié
en fin de compte à la position du sénat
avec une nuance il est vrai puisqu'on a
rajouté sur les questions nouvelles
en d'autres termes il faut faire en
sorte que le collège ne soit pas
submergés par une multitude de requêtes
et de recours divers notamment le ski un
caractère répétitif ou un caractère
annexe à ces recours et par conséquent
nous avons accepté cette rédaction
dès lors nous avions réglé l'essentiel
de nos désaccords et il restait à régler
quelques petits problèmes de données
plus ou moins contraignantes
moi je fais confiance au bon
fonctionnement de l'institution du
défenseur des droits des pratiques vont
se développer je rappelle par exemple
que le problème de la motivation des
actes du médiateur n'était pas prévue
par les textes
le médiateur le seul est imposé je suis
convaincu que le défenseur des droits
sera de même voilà donc par conséquent
nous sommes arrivés à un terrain
d'entente sur l'essentiel du texte et
c'est la raison pour laquelle sur la loi
organique je demanderai mes chers
collègues de bien vouloir vous rallier
aux conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire
en ce qui concerne la loi ordinaire j'ai
peu de chose a ajouté
compte tenu que l'accord existait des
pratiquement la première lecture entre
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat sur la
loi ordinaire
il ya juste eu ce problème qui avait
fait l'objet d'une discussion parmi nous
lors de la deuxième lecture
ça a été les l'ensemble des amendements
déposés à l'assemblée nationale lors de
sa première lecture concernant la la
cnil saviez que ces amendements étaient
rendus nécessaires par le fait que toute
une série de décisions de la cnil
risquait de devenir inopérante et que
par conséquent l'accent de la cnil
risquait d'être paralysé si nous
n'adopterons pas ses textes donc par
conséquent même si le lien est très
ténue entre la cnil d'une part et le
défenseur des droits il existe le lien
existe mais il est un peu lointain eh
bien nous avons nous avions première en
deuxième lecture accepté au sénat
d'adopter l'ensemble de ces amendements
bon ces amendements ont été complétés
par deux amendements complémentaires qui
ont été acceptées par la commission
mixte paritaire
je suis pas convaincu car et d'axa soit
parfaite mais je pense qu'il faut le
faire et que par conséquent le devant
nous rallier à cette proposition de la
commission mixte paritaire pour
permettre à la cnil au moins jusqu'au
renouvellement de son président qui
viendra à l'automne tu avais à la cnil
de fonctionner correctement d'ici par
conséquent je demanderai mes chers
collègues
là encore de suivre les conclusions de
la commission mixte paritaire et pour
conclure je vous dirais monsieur le
président monsieur le garde des sceaux
ce président chers collègues que je
souhaite bonne chance au futur défenseur
des droits etc surtout que je souhaite
qu'on choisisse enfin l'oiseau rare qui
nous permettra de faire en sorte que ce
défenseur des droits rendent pleinement
valeur à cette nouvelle institution
merci patrice gélard monsieur le
rapporteur et la parole est à monsieur
michel mercier garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice et des libertés
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mais c'est à dire des commissions des
lois monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs 10 sénateurs comme
vient excellemment de leur rappeler le
noyage l'air nous arrivons au terme de
la procédure parlementaire
et c'est à dire que dans quelques
instants vous allez créer le défenseur
des droits en tous les cas n'ont pas
créé puisque c'est la constitution et il
l'a fait mais lui donner les moyens de
fonctionner et avant d'entrer dans les
détails mais ce très bref puisque le day
âge et leur a fort bien résumé les
choses
je voudrais dire que les textes qui sont
soumis à l'examen du sénat aujourd'hui
feront probablement et du défenseur des
droits français et non bussmann plus
puissant d'europe
je crois qu'il faut le savoir le dire et
et porter cette loi l'institution et je
voudrais dire aussi au sénat qu'il faut
replacer la création du défenseur des
droits
dans un ensemble de textes qui ont été
votées par cette majorité et qui ont eu
pour objectif d'étendre la protection
des libertés publiques
je crois que trop souvent on ne dit pas
et il y a peu de gouvernements qui
remportait aussi haut et aussi largement
la protection de libertés publiques
je voudrais rappeler quelques uns de ses
textes c'est bien sûr elle la question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité nous
le voyons tous les jours
l'espagne c'est bizarre le d'accord
madame la présidente je comprends bien
que je dise
ou gêne parce que ça vous rappeler
toutes les occasions vous avez manqué
d'apporter votre pierre à cette
construction en faveur des libertés
publiques mais un côté de la question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité il
faut rajouter la loi pénitentiaire qui
barque de vrais progrès l'institution du
contrôleur des lieux de privation de
liberté
j'ajouterai il y a quelques jours à
peine la loi sur la garde à vue
il ya là un ensemble de textes qui vont
dans le même sens et je crois qu'il faut
dé présenter ainsi le défenseur des
droits prend tout à fait sa place dans
un cet ensemble comme il a été dit la
commission paritaire est parvenu à un
accord et le gouvernement accepte cet
exercice s'ouvre à des parlementaires au
sein de la cmp
peut-être que le texte d'origine
monsieur le doyen n'était il pas aussi
un parfait que vous avez bien voulu le
dire mais non mais non mais non mais non
mais et si vous voulez dire que le
gouvernement avec de senna croix ou
mérité aux vertus du débat parlementaire
vous avez raison de le dire parce que je
suis en tout cas personnellement et le
gouvernement d'assad en sommes très
attachés
ce débat parlementaire et c'est vrai que
nous sommes d'arrivée je crois à un bon
accord un bon texte et qui donnera au
défenseur des droits tous les moyens de
fonctionner alors vous avez assisté sur
le rôle du sénat et vous avez eu raison
parce que dès la première lecture le
sénat à la fois étendu que le périmètre
de l'institution en y introduisant les
missions de la halde est fixée déco
cours de l'organisation interne de la
nouvelle autorité constitutionnelle
il a prévu des adjoints et il a organisé
lé collège il a d'ailleurs prévu
auch 1 et des adjoints l'un d'entre eux
qui portera le titre de défenseur des
enfants pour qu'ils soient
particulièrement identifié et sur un
domaine d'action extrêmement sensible
auquel nous tenons tous à ce que c'est
ce domaine là soit particulièrement un
bien être traitée et le cdh a
considérablement développé des collèges
placé auprès du défenseur des droits
pour l'éclairer ainsi le défenseur des
droits disposera-t-il de tous les moyens
propres à garantir l'efficacité de son
action sur les apports qui nous viennent
de la commission mixte paritaire est d
accord auquel n'avaient pas venu je
crois qu'il y en a deux le rapporteur
elle les a rappelés je veux à mon tour
dire que grâce à ces travaux est le
défenseur des droits devra désormais
obligatoirement consulté les collèges
placé au point de lui lorsqu'il est
saisi d'une question nouvelle je veux
simplement rappeler aux rapporteurs
notamment qui est un éminent
constitutionnaliste que la constitution
ceci elle prévoit l'existence des
collèges
elle limite aussi la rose puisqu'elle
dit très clairement pour l'assister pas
plus pas moi mais pour l'assister et on
peut donc rester et que dans le domaine
de l'assistance et et non pas il
n'appartient pas au collège décider il
appartient au collège est d'éclairer
d'assister le défenseur des droits et je
crois que la formule à laquelle s'est
ralliée la commission mixte paritaire
toute bonne formule puisqu'elle
permettra d'assurer la participation des
collèges à l'élaboration de la pratique
institutionnelle du défenseur des droits
sans que ses collègues soient par
ailleurs submergé milliers de demandes
où ils n'auraient pas de vrai rôle à
jouer et je regrette d'ailleurs que dans
la pratique notamment de la halde la
plus grande partie de la sphère de passe
pas dans le collège parce que c'était
impossible parce que c'est impossible et
qu'il n'y avait pas
deux collèges pour le défenseur des
enfants et dieu sait si on nous a
appelés partout et notamment ici au
sénat les conditions excellentes de
fonctionnement du défenseur des enfants
donc c'est très bien il y à des collèges
et oui mais on nous a dit des centaines
de fois donc sans collège ça
fonctionnait bien et sans adjoint
d'ailleurs et là il y aura et adjoints
et collèges donc ça va être encore mieux
qu'avant et c'est vrai tu avais été
mieux qu'avant parce que défenseur des
droits pas plus de pouvoir que défenseur
des enfants et il faut pas l'oublier
puis le deuxième point important il
ressort des travaux de la commission
mixte paritaire consiste à imposer au
défenseur des droits
d'expliciter les motifs pour lesquels il
décide de ne pas donner de suite à une
réclamation dont il est saisi
gouvernement vous savez n'était pas
favorable à cette mesure pour des
raisons de cohérence cette obligation
demeurera sans sanction puisque les
actes du défenseur des droits de fonds
ne feront pas grief et ne pourront par
conséquent pas être déféré devant le
juge il n'en reste pas moins vrai qu'il
est normal qu'une institution au service
de la protection des droits et libertés
des personnes fassent connaître les
raisons qui peuvent très légitimement la
conduire à ne pas répondre favorablement
à une demande aussi le gouvernement s
arrange t il sagement à la position du
parlement à ce qui concerne les
dispositions du projet de loi ordinaire
sur la commission nationale informatique
et libertés il rappelle que si le
gouvernement les a introduites à
l'assemblée nationale c'était pour
permettre à la cnil de continuer à
fonctionner et on va sentir à ces deux
termes large dans tous les sens du monde
et que je crois qu'il faut le dire très
clairement je souhaite attirer
attention sur un point qui nous paraît
pas excellent et comme le rapporteur le
dit lui même je pense que la cnil aura
la sagesse de ne pas se servir de ce qui
n'est pas excellent dans le texte et
cela ira très bien ainsi je souhaite
enfin attirer l'attention un du sénat
son dispositif choisi pour l'entrée en
vigueur du défenseur des droits
celle ci se fera en deux temps afin de
pallier la fin du mandat du médiateur de
la république le 31 mars prochain
ainsi dès la promulgation de la loi un
défenseur des droits sera nommé remplira
les missions actuellement dévolues au
médiateur de la république
deux mois plus tard le défenseur des
droits remplira la totalité des missions
qui lui sont confiées
la cmp a précisé que l'entrée en vigueur
des deux textes seraient concomitante
notamment dans le cas où le conseil
constitutionnel ne serait pas saisi et
sur les deux textes simplement quelques
observations que je voulais faire
rappelant l'accord du gouvernement sur
les conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire
merci monsieur le ministre
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à jean pierre sueur
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le
défenseur des droits pourquoi pas s'il
s'agit de plus de droit de plus de
liberté de plus d'indépendance à l'égard
de tous les pouvoirs et notamment du
pouvoir exécutif monsieur le ministre
or vous savez bien qu'il n'en est rien
la réalité
nous l'avons déjà dit il se trouve que
le défenseur des enfants a fait preuve
de beaucoup d'indépendance d'esprit et
c'est monsieur le président de la
commission des lois
vos paroles n'engagent que vous mais
elle vous engage bien sûr comme toujours
monsieur le rapporteur et solidaire très
bien donc
le défenseur des droits s'est
transportée dans les centres de
rétention pour voir comment les enfants
y étaient traités que défenseur des
enfants la halde s'est intéressé en un
temps aux tests adn
si cher au pouvoir exécutif
non pas à vous monsieur mercier vous 9
navale apparteniez pas encore au pouvoir
exécutif
vous étiez sénateurs la cnds a fait un
travail absolument remarquable en toute
indépendance sur ces questions très
difficiles de la déontologie des forces
de sécurité police et gendarmerie
beaucoup d'indépendance beaucoup de
sérieux
beaucoup de travail
or nous avons dit et malheureusement
nous devons redire que la nouvelle
construction qui sera adoptée par la
majorité du parlement
elle reprend les choses en main elle
centralise monsieur le ministre
et on est là dans un nouvel avatar de ce
que notre ami robert badinter appelle la
monocratie certes vous contesterait ce
terme et vous contestez toujours ce
terme monsieur le ministre
toutefois il est patent que le défenseur
des droits est nommé par le président de
la république après des consultations
qui n'auront pas d'effet il est patent
que les adjoints sont proposés par le
défenseur des droits
nommé par le président de la république
et qu'ils sont nommés par le premier
ministre
j'avais dit en seconde lecture le
pouvoir exécutif plus le pouvoir
exécutif plus le pouvoir exécutif égale
le pouvoir exécutif monsieur le ministre
quel progrès vers l'indépendance
mais vous le savez vous-mêmes qu'il
s'agit d'une construction qui ne
préserve pas l'indépendance des entités
qui est nous ne l'avons pas contesté
monsieur le rapporteur
bien qu'elles fussent nommé par le
président de la république avait conquis
respect autorité indépendante mais là de
quoi s'agit-il
il s'agit de tout mettre sous la même
autorité
les adjoints on en a assez parlé seront
disons le des collaborateurs terme cher
en un temps à monsieur le président de
la république
ils n'auront pas d'autonomie vous le
savez très bien et ce qui a été
décidée par la commission mixte
paritaire ne nous rassure pas à cet
effet donc notre position sera la même
que lors des lectures précédente
nous avons fait des propositions en
particulier notre position us était très
différente si vous aviez accepté que les
adjoints défenseur des enfants halde
cnds fussent désigné par le parlement
par le parlement il y à des majorités
il y a des il ya des pays où de telles
instances de telle autorité sont
désignés par le parlement et pourquoi
pas à une large majorité du parlement ce
qui supposerait un accord entre la
majorité et l'opposition
cela mais je sais que vous ne voulez pas
de cela nous persistons à proposer cela
parce que de tels modes de désignation
garantir est assurément la totale
indépendance de ses instances et de ses
autorités
alors s'il fallait des arguments
complémentaires il suffirait de lire le
compte rendu de la commission mixte
paritaire
certes et je veux en donner acte à
monsieur e
j'ai là notre rapporteur
le texte du sénat présenter des
avantages par rapport à celui de
l'assemblée
c'est une réalité ce n'est pas la
première fois
c'est souvent le cas c'est pourquoi il y
a eu quelques avancées dues au sénat
mais je dirais que plutôt que d'avancer
il s'agit peut être de moindre recul
en tout cas il y a quatre points qui
sont quand même très significatif au
terme de la commission mixte paritaire
le défenseur des droits est la seule
personne qui puisse juridiquement être
saisie
c'est un chef-d'oeuvre de centralisation
on ne peut pas envoyer une lettre au
défenseur des enfants auxquels à
laquelle ou auxquelles ont fait
l'honneur de maintenir son titre et oui
oui on lui fait l'honneur de maintenir
son titre ce qui n'est pas l'honneur
fait aux autres collaborateurs
mais le défenseur des enfants ne pourra
pas recevoir de lettre
si quelqu'un a écrit au défenseur des
enfants il retournera inconnu à
l'adresse indiquée
il transmettra au défenseur des droits
qui lui fera connaître le contenu de la
lettre au défenseur des enfants s'il le
veut bien
une seule personne reçoit tout sans
compter tous ceux qui arrivent au
médiateur de la république
on est bien d'accord c'est une sorte
d'autorité suprême désigne et
souverainement et au pouvoir souverain
on est vraiment dans la logique des
autorités indépendantes n'est ce pas je
dis cela avec quelque peu d'ironie vous
l'aurez compris monsieur le ministre
deuxièmement il n'y a pas de possibilité
de demander une seconde délibération
nous l'aurions souhaité le sénat
l'aurait souhaité mais au terme de la
commission mixte paritaire vous avez
bien lu monsieur le ministre cela
n'existe pas troisièmement pour ce qui
est de la consultation des collèges
le sénat avait adopté ce verbe simple et
cet indicatif valant impératif selon la
juste leçons de grammaire de monsieur
gélard consulte mais l'assemblée
nationale ne voulais pas que l'on
consulte a simplement
donc on va consulter pour toutes
questions nouvelles
oui mais monsieur le président qu'est ce
que c'est qu'une question nouvelle c'est
certainement mieux que ce que voulaient
écrire l'assemblée nationale eh oui il y
à des degrés dans le jugement monsieur
le président
mais qu'est ce que c'est qu'une question
nouvelle et je pose la question en
particulier par rapport aux attributions
de la cnds commission nationale de
déontologie de la sécurité
monsieur le doyen gélard vous venez de
dire quelque chose d'important et cela
sera inscrit au procès verbal et cela
mais cela très bien sera inscrit au
procès verbal et aidera à interpréter le
texte monsieur le doyen vous avez dit
chaque cas sera nouveau autrement dit
vous avez dit que pour le rapporteur est
le monsieur le ministre est important
pour le rapporteur de la commission des
lois du sénat
là le collège de la cnds devra être
saisie pour consultation de chaque cas
on est bien d'accord
c'est une avancée dont je vous remercie
monsieur le doyen parce que c'est vrai
que sans votre intervention à cet
instant et qui est lourde de
signification et je vous en remercie
il y aurait une grande ambiguïté parce
que on peut toujours considérer que
pratiquement les cas eu de déficiences
par rapport à la déontologie de la
police ou de la gendarmerie ont déjà été
traités mais dans ces cas là ce qui
compte et vous le savez bien et nous
devons rendre hommage au travail de
monsieur beauvois et de tous les membres
de la cnds et de leurs rapports
extrêmement éclairant pour nous
parlementaires
et bien ce qui est important c'est de
regarder à chaque fois les circonstances
de l'espèce
qu'est ce qui s'est passé à ce moment là
en cet endroit là dans ces circonstances
là ce qui amène cette commission a
enquêté à regarder les témoignages
autrement dit il ne s'agit pas de
regarder des déficiences ou des
manquements qui sont en quelque chose en
quelque sorte normes et stéréotypé mais
il s'agit de regarder des situations
concrètes toujours nouvelles comme vient
de le dire monsieur g là et nous pensons
kiel ce qu'il aurait été bon que qu'il
en aille ainsi monsieur le ministre pour
l'ensemble des collèges alors qui
décidera que la question est nouvelle ou
qu'elle n'est pas nouvelle
pas le collège le défenseur des droits
dans sa souveraineté
s'il dit cette affaire là n'est pas
nouvelle il n'y a pas de recours
il n'y a pas de discussion ce n'est pas
nouveau circulez il n'ya rien à voir
le collège il n'est pas saisie mais
c'est la vérité c'est la vérité du test
que vous vous apprêtez à voter mes chers
collègues de la majorité dont nous nous
pensons que cette question de nouvelles
sera lourde eu d'ambiguïté et que la
formule consulte avait le mérite de la
clarté de la force et de la sincérité
enfin je note
j'avais cru comprendre le contraire mais
malheureusement la réalité est ce
qu'elle est que le défenseur des droits
monsieur le ministre s'il ne suit pas
l'avis d'un collège d'un de ces fameux
quatre collèges il n'est pas tenu de
motiver sa décision
vous qui êtes un grand juriste monsieur
le garde des sceaux est ce que vous
trouvez cela fondées moi je trouve que
dans le cas où un collège constitué de
spécialistes éminents désigné par le
président du sénat et le président de
l'assemblée nationale donne un avis
après étude examen et que le défenseur
des droits dits non je ne suis pas la
vie il devrait pour le moins a expliqué
pourquoi il ne suit pas l'avis donc
motivés dont vous en tant que garde des
sceaux
vous trouvez que le fait qu'il n'y ait
pas de motivation est magnifique mais
absolument mais absolument monsieur le
ministre
donc vous nous direz mais vous me
permettrez aussi de dire ce que j'en
pense et de considérer
oui oui mais est de considérer qu'il
serait qu'ils oui mais nous avions 35
minutes
monsieur le ministre donc je vous je
vous invite à réfléchir à ce à quoi vous
avez échappé monsieur le ministre
donc je conclus jeu conclut monsieur le
ministre si vous si vous cessez les
obstructions monsieur le ministre je
vais conclure en disant qu'après avoir
exposé ses différents points
naturellement je me permets une petite
remarque qui peut-être ne plaira pas à
tout le monde
nous avons lu la presse
encore ce matin je pense que vous l'avez
lu monsieur le ministre
et nous voyons un certain nombre d' un
2-2 d'articles d'annonce si après tout
cela le défenseur des droits serait
nommé serait une personne qui serait
choisi certes pour ses grandes qualités
dont je ne discute pas mais pour régler
le problème particulier qui serait posée
dans une ville de france ces grandes
d'ailleurs par le fait que le
rédécoupage des circonscriptions aurait
pour effet de supprimer une
circonscription où de faire que deux
personnes du même parti se trouverait
sur la même circonscription
il sera ici il s'agirait là de quelque
chose d'assez pitoyable et d'assez peu
monsieur monsieur jean-pierre michel dit
le qualificatif qui lui convient le
mieux
quelque chose de tout à fait
incompréhensible
il est clair que nous sommes en
désaccord avec la conception du
défenseur des droits
mais si en plus cela était peu utilisé
cette nouvelle institution non pas pour
mettre en place une personnalité qui
aurait toute l'autorité la compétence et
l'indépendance nécessaires mais pour
régler un problème lié au redécoupage
des circonscriptions
vous comprendrez que cela susciterait
quand même de vives critiques dans notre
pays
vous aurez compris monsieur le ministre
que notre groupe votera contre
le projet de loi organique et le projet
de loi ordinaire
merci jean pierre sueur la parole est à
notre collègue jacques mézard
toujours attendre
et
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues avant de
choisir l'oiseau rare qui aura
certainement un certain nombre d'heures
de vol en évitant je n'en doute pas les
rapaces et les autruches de faire
prendre son envol à cet oiseau rare il
fallait évidemment construire son nid
simplement d'ailleurs pour appliquer la
constitution qu'on l'ait voter ou qu'on
l'ait pas voter il convient de
l'appliquer regrouper les autorités
administratives indépendantes faire
cesser la multiplication de ces
autorités
ça nous paraît nous dans la conception
une bonne chose car trop d'autorité
indépendante
ça a abouti à la dissolution ont la
dilution plutôt de l'autorité de ces
autorités plus de pouvoir plus
d'indépendance pour faire respecter les
droits mais un point c'est tout ces
autorités
cette autorité ne doit pas se substituer
ni à la justice ni au pouvoir exécutif
la création de cette nouvelle autorité
publique indépendante
peut-être pouvait être une avancée pour
le comité balladur sur la modernisation
des institutions elle avait vocation et
je cite à être substituée à l'ensemble
des autorités administratives
indépendantes qui oeuvrent dans le champ
de la protection des libertés et
recevant autorité sur ceux de leurs
services qui seraient appelés à
subsister mais les débats sur
l'application du nouvel article 71 1 de
la constitution augurer assez mal de la
naissance de cette autorité puisque
la garde des sceaux de l'époque madame
dati avait soigneusement entretenu le
flou sur les contours exacts des
missions du défenseur des droits
le sénat et en particulier son
rapporteur le doyen gélard a beaucoup et
bien le vrai nous tenons à le réaffirmer
mais c'est justement cette imprécision
que nous avions dénoncé tout au long de
la navette
étant donné que le périmètre du
défenseur des droits n'a cessé d'enfler
de rétrécir au gré des lectures
ce manque de clarté a surtout mis en
lumière le fait que le gouvernement
avait décidément bien du mal à définir
ce qu'il attendait du défenseur des
droits
sauf qu'il souhaitait en faire un
médiateur de la république aux pouvoirs
élargis
si je viens compris pour autant le fait
est que notre paysage institutionnel est
aujourd'hui marquée par la
multiplication c'est un constat de ces
autorités administratives dites
indépendantes dont le champ d'action est
souvent dé multiplier de manière lisible
pour beaucoup de nos concitoyens perdu
dans les subtilités des arcanes de
l'administration
l'application de l'article 71 1 par
cette application le défenseur des
droits est chargé d'exercer une
compétence générale en matière de
protection des droits et libertés est ce
que nous y sommes par rapport à ce texte
je n'en suis pas encore convaincu
nous nous sommes donc prononcé nous dès
la première lecture et je le réaffirme
aujourd'hui en faveur du regroupement de
certaines de ces autorités
lorsque leur domaine de compétence
présenter une cohérence en matière de
protection des droits fondamentaux
et c'est dans cet esprit que nous avions
approuvé dès la première lecture que les
compétences de la halde et du défenseur
des enfants soient fondues dans celles
du défenseur des droits au nom d'une
nécessaire rationalisation des
périmètres d'intervention d'autres
autorités selon nous d'ailleurs aurait
pu être intégrée elle aussi mais en
l'état ce
dispositif en tout cas nous paraissait
justifié l'assemblée nationale a suivi
le vote du sénat sur un certain nombre
de points comme le champ de la
compétence de règlement des différends
pouvant surgir entre personnes morales
ou encore la suppression de la
possibilité qu'ils étaient offertes aux
défenseurs d'introduire une procédure
d'action collective devant la
juridiction administrative et sur ce
dernier point il nous paraissait sage
raisonnable de poursuivre assez
longuement la réflexion nous nous
réjouissons que l'assemblée nationale
ait finalement entendu la voix du sénat
en renonçant à supprimer le contrôleur
général des lieux de privation de
liberté
nous avions défendu l'idée que la
mission du contrôleur est d'une nature
très spécifique puisqu'il est amené à
intervenir directement de son propre
fait et de façon inopinée pour contrôler
le respect de droits fondamentaux en
tous lieux de privation de liberté
cette mission de contrôle est essentiel
pour les libertés dans notre pays et il
est donc heureux que ce contrôleur
puissent continuer à travailler
indépendamment avec les remarquables
compétences que tout le monde lui
reconnaît aujourd'hui beaucoup moins
heureux selon nous et le vote conforme
de l'assemblée du sénat relatif à la
suppression de la cnds intégré au
défenseur des droits
nos collègues députés ont considéré pour
nous de manière très contestable que les
compétences de la cnds pouvait être
intégrée à celle du défenseur en
procédant de la même logique que pour le
contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté
nous ne comprenons toujours pas pour
quelle raison a été refusé la
disparition du contrôleur pour accepter
celle de la cnts alors même qu'elle
exerce des missions assez semblable
temps dans leurs modalités que dans leur
finalité et on peut donc s'inquiéter de
l'effectivité du contrôle des forces de
l'ordre
car il y à certains cas qui jusqu'ici se
contrôler surtout dans le climat
politique particulier que nous
connaissons actuellement de façon
globale pour nous la cmp n'a pas lever
certains doutes que nous avions exprimé
sur l'ensemble de ces deux textes le
défenseur des droits est peut-être une
ambition pour la république et nous
verrons en fonction d'ailleurs des choix
qui seront faits du fonctionnement mais
nous ne pouvons que déplorer que cette
ambition est été en partie altérée par
de nombreuses zones d'ombrés qui
demeurent pour certaines car le
défenseur des droits concentrera bel et
bien des missions qui relèvent de deux
logiques différentes à savoir le
contrôle et la médiation au détriment
sans doute de l'impératif d'effectivité
des droits comme le relevé la commission
nationale consultative des droits de
l'homme
l'étude d'impact le reconnaissait
d'ailleurs le regroupement de l'ensemble
des autorités chargées de la protection
des droits et libertés et je cite
conduirait à conjuguer les missions
actuelles de médiation avec des missions
de contrôle de décisions ou de sanctions
qui sont différentes et pourrait
s'avérer contre-productif sur ce point
nous ne sommes toujours pas convaincus
car une des missions sera
vraisemblablement privilégiées mais
l'interrogation la plus fondamentale
inhérentes à l'essence du défenseur des
droits
concerne naturellement son mode de
désignation
ainsi que celui de ses adjoints pour
nous l'indépendance est un élément
fondamental de l'efficacité et de la
crédibilité de son action effectivement
le choix qui sera fait de cet oiseau
rare sera fondamental pour le lancement
à la fois dans le concret dans l'opinion
de ce défenseur des droits
indépendance fondamental et il est vrai
que le mode de domination du médiateur
de la république n'a jamais empêché les
différents titulaires de la fonction
d'exercer leurs attributions toute
indépendance il faut savoir aussi le
reconnaître pour autant
il eût été à l'honneur du parlement de
renforcer encore les garanties
d'indépendance
nous avons ainsi déploré que
l'application de l'article 13 de la
constitution prévoit la nomination du
défenseur des droits par décret en
conseil des ministres sous réserve d'une
majorité négative des trois cinquièmes
des suffrages exprimés au sein des deux
commissions permanentes compétentes
il en va de même pour la nomination de
ses adjoints qui seront nommés par le
premier ministre sans possibilité pour
le parlement de donner son avis sur la
question des trois collèges chargés
d'assister le défenseur nous nous
satisfaisons que la cmp est finalement
retenu des articles 11 12 et 12 bis dans
la rédaction ont voté par le sénat il
nous paraît en effet plus conforme à
l'esprit non partisan que les membres du
collège comprennent outre des
personnalités qualifiées par le
président de chaque assemblée des
personnalités issues de la cour de
cassation et du conseil d'état
dans la même logique nous à nous nous
satisfaisons également que le caractère
obligatoire de la consultation de chacun
de ces collèges et été rendus
obligatoires comme le souhaitait le
sénat l'on pouvait dans le cas contraire
s'interroger sur l'utilité même de ces
collèges si leurs consultations
n'étaient que facultatifs
s'agissant des autres points de
désaccord entre nos deux assemblées
les divergences étaient finalement assez
mineur au regard de l'accord trouvé sur
le périmètre du défenseur avec les
critiques que j'ai rappelé en ce qui
nous concerne nous voulons nous
l'obligation soit faite au défenseur des
droits de motiver ses décisions de ne
pas donner suite à une saisine
c'est également à ce titre que nous
pouvons souscrire à l'obligation qui est
faite d'établir un rapport spécial qui
sera publié en cas d'injonction non
suivies d'effet autre point mais très
différents si nous partageons
les objectifs concernant le problème de
la cnil nous remarquons quand même que
les articles 1er bis a promis érotise du
projet de loi ordinaire présente un lien
plus que ténue avec le reste du texte
malgré les explications monsieur le
garde des sceaux il et les cavaliers
voir des escadrons qui ont le droit de
se lancer dans le champ de courses
législatif et d'autres non pour en
constater les dispositions relatives à
l'entrée en vigueur des deux textes ont
également donné lieu à des divergences
entre nos deux chambres mais il faut
remarquer que nous nous serions
facilement passer de ce débat si le
gouvernement n'avait pas accumuler les
retards dans le dépôt et la discussion
de ces deux projets de loi il est aussi
vrai que notre ordre du jour est
monopolisé par des textes considérés
comme plus important que la préservation
des droits fondamentaux de nos
concitoyens là aussi constatations le
défenseur des droits verra donc le jour
plus de deux ans et demi après la
révision constitutionnelle du 23 juillet
il y à des textes très urgent et
d'autres qui paraissent moins urgents
nous en avons comprenant bien les
raisons même si nous les contestions
fortement au final et malgré le travail
de la cmp
nous continuons à considérer que ces
deux textes pêche sur un problème de
principe du fait d'ailleurs qui découle
de l'application de l'article 13 de la
constitution et nous regrettons je les
dis que la cnds n'ait pu être sauvés
même si nous saluons le maintien du
contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté donc globalement
après irene le bilan entre les avancées
et puis ceux qui n'en constitue pas
notre groupe très majoritairement
s'abstiendra sur ce texte
merci jacques mézard la parole est à la
présidente nicole borvo cohen seat
bonjour madame la présidente monsieur le
président monsieur le garde des sceaux
michel collègues
alors monsieur le garde des sceaux
permettez moi de vous dire puisque vous
m'avez interpellé que je n'ai pas
vraiment honte de ne pas partager
l'autosatisfaction dont vous faites
preuve concernant les droits et libertés
je vous en donnerai deux raisons très
simples pour l'instant d'une part parce
que les lois que vous avez cités loi
pénitentiaire aux gardes à vue ont été
des décisions contraintes du
gouvernement condamné à de multiples
reprises sur le plan européen pour
précisément les manquements de la france
en matière de détention soit en prison
son garde à vue donc contraints et
forcés et réforme a minima
la qpc est à double tranchant je les dis
et la situation actuelle me permets de
le redire parce que compte tenu de la
composition du conseil constitutionnel
nous ne nous sommes totalement opposés à
ce qu'il devienne une cour suprême
ensuite je vous ferai observé que votre
gouvernement vous aidez ceux qui vous
ont précédés ont quand même mener des
politiques qui ont eu pour conséquence
de réduire considérablement les droits
et libertés de manière incessante nous
sommes amenés à examiner
et vous notre majorité à voter des
textes qui sont des véritables
régressions des droits fondamentaux pour
ne citer que les derniers la loppsi 2 le
la loi dite besson et sans parler des
droits économiques et sociaux qui comme
vous le savez font partie intégrante des
droits fondamentaux depuis de la
constitution de 1946 alors si vous
voulez moi j'ai par contre je crois
qu'on a
participer de la défense des libertés de
beaucoup de personnes
et donc je continuerai dans ce sens
alors en matière d'affichage par contre
évidemment le pouvoir n'est pas avare en
2008 il était annoncé la création d'un
grand défenseur doté d'une grande
autorité morale haut placé dans la
hiérarchie des normes tout un évidement
l'annoncent était fantastique
mais le fait de l'inscrire dans la
constitution est sans doute une
condition mais elle est loin d'être
suffisante
dès le début on a vu un certain nombre
de problèmes notamment liés à la
nomination mais aussi à l'incertitude et
le flou dans son mode d'intervention
sami un certain temps d'ailleurs à se
décider et ensuite sur le fait qu
effectivement comme le disait notre
collègue à l'instant que ce que je
partage le fait qu'il y avait confusion
entre contrôle et médiation et qu'on
voyait bien qu'il s'agissait surtout de
médiation qui dont il était question
la nomination par le président de la
république d'autres l'ont dit avant moi
et sonner comme une reprise en main des
autorités administratives indépendantes
qui de fait devaient être supprimés même
si vos prédécesseurs ont laissé pendant
tout un temps planer un doute sur la
question
donc nos inquiétudes et notre position
puisque nous nous y sommes opposés ne se
sont pas arrangées et même elle ne l ont
continué à croître à l'évidence
l'ensemble du processus a eu un fils
conducteurs faire du défenseur une
autorité unique dotée de pouvoirs
discrétionnaires et habilités
directement par le président de la
république vous avez décidé la
suppression du défenseur des enfants
une première en europe ou celle inverse
qui a cours c'est à dire que de plus en
plus de défenseur des enfants ont été
établies je dis bien établies parce
qu'après les mode de nomination sont
divers
alors qu'il existait d'autres
institutions concernant les droits
mais la spécificité des enfants est
reconnue de plus en plus vous avez
décidé la suppression de la sienne est
ce une régression dénoncé par son
président actuel qui n'est pourtant pas
qui est monsieur beauvois et régression
et vivante puisque on va essayer quand
même de mettre quelques freins à au
travail que fait la cnds vous n'avez
même pas requis leur avis d'ailleurs ni
celui de la cndh pourtant directement
concerné a fortiori vous ne les avez pas
entendu puisque vous ne les avez pas
consultés cela ne suffisait pas sans
prendre le temps du débat notre
rapporteur d'ailleurs lui a voté a fait
voter la disparition de la halde avec
l'approbation du gouvernement
cette décision a suscité l'opposition
d'associations diverses antiraciste de
syndicats d'associations d'handicapés
vous venez comme moi de recevoir un
courrier de la présidente du comité
consultatif de la halde
madame marie-thérèse lanquetin elle
souligne je partage ce qu'elle lit que
le projet en l'état ne peut que jeter la
suspicion sur ce qui est présenté comme
une avancée dans la lutte contre les
discriminations il y a deux jours à
l'occasion du 8 mars la halde qui
existent encore jusqu'ici faisait des
recommandations pour lutter contre les
discriminations à l'égard des femmes
est ce que ces recommandations auront un
avenir on peut en douter puisque
évidemment ça fait quand même un bout de
temps que ceux qui se préoccupent des
libertés se bat contre les
discriminations à l'égard des femmes
vous voyez bien que c'est un sujet qui
paraît difficile à contrer par contre la
disparition de la halde a trouvé un
supporters en la personne de monsieur
zemmour condamné pour provocation à la
haine raciale et pourtant reçu avec
bienveillance à l'assemblée nationale
par des députés de l'ump
et il a donné des conseils il a dit vous
avez supprimé la halle de continuer est
supprimé l'action pénale pour les
associations antiracistes et même leurs
subventions
vous voyez vous avez des défenseurs
vous allez chercher vos défenseurs je
trouve à des endroits un petit peu
suspect jusqu'où irez vous quand une
députée de la majorité rapporteure
générale de l'observatoire de la parité
madame chantal brunel reprend la
proposition de madame le pen de renvoyer
sur leurs bateaux les immigrés venant de
méditerranée
les députés de la majorité ont ajouté
aux missions du défenseur celle du
contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté leur tentative a
fort heureusement avortée avec l'aide de
notre rapporteur et nous la saluons bien
entendu car sa mission pour l'instant
demeurera et elle je crois qu'elle va
demeurer de la plus grande utilité si
l'on en croit une proposition phare
émises par le député eric ciotti
secrétaire national de l'ump en charge
de la sécurité lors d'une convention qui
se tenait ce mardi dernier 8 mars
vingt mille places supplémentaires de
prison à l'horizon 2017 au lieu des
quatorze mille prévus
voilà continuer à ouvrir des prisons et
s'adonnera du moulleau passe au
contrôleur général des prisons parce que
franchement la loi pénitentiaire est
loin d'être appliquée les autorités qui
vont disparaître ont su faire preuve
d'efficacité et à l'épreuve parce que
bien entendu elles sont nommés par
l'exécutif ce que d'ailleurs je rappelle
nous avons critiqué en son temps
qu'elles soient nommés par l'exécutif
mais elles ont su faire preuve
d'efficacité à l'épreuve de leur
présence sur le terrain de leurs
spécificités de leurs spécialités de
leur indépendance
et ce n'est pas ce qui va se passer avec
le défenseur apparemment des prises de
positions qu'elles ont eu l'occasion de
prendre dérange la défenseure des
enfants a émis des critiques sur les
conséquences de votre politique sociale
ou d'immigration sur les enfants la cnds
a souvent mis à jour le comportement de
certains commissariats ou de certains
policiers et la halde a dénoncé
l'existence discrimination dans les
grandes entreprises discrimination à
l'embauché
il est à l'origine chez airbus par
exemple discrimination salariale liée au
genre
à la grossesse et à la situation de
famille de la bnp et ça ça ne plaît pas
aux amis du président vous avez décidé
leur fusion sans égard ou fort peu
envers la spécificité de chacune d'entre
elles
qu'il s'agisse de leur mode de saisine
ou d'intervention de leur composition
nous avons pu croire un instant que la
défenseure des enfants était sauvé
c'était sans compter sur les fréquentes
volte face de la majorité devant les
exigences du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur vous
n'avez cessé d'invoquer l'article 61-1
de la constitution pour faire pièce aux
amendements de l'opposition
vous nous avez dit en quelque sorte
qu'est la loi organique ne pouvait pas
grand chose puisque la constitution
elle-même offrait peu de marge de
manoeuvre
c'est pourtant bien la constitution qui
renvoie à la loi organique pour définir
les modalités de mise en oeuvre
défenseur donc il y avait une marge de
manoeuvre vous le savez très bien
disons le clairement l'article 71 1
était destiné à concentrer pouvoirs et
missions autour sur la seule personne du
défenseur nommé par le seul président de
la république et vous en tient que vous
entendiez bien en rester là
lors de la réforme constitutionnelle ce
qui nous était dit et surtout ceux qui
n'étaient pas dit nous faisait craindre
un recul pour la protection des droits
et des libertés
ce recul se profile de manière évidente
dans la nomination du défenseur des
droits le parlement droit que le rôle
que lui confère la 13 celui de figurant
si vous me permettez l'expression
avant même d'être désigné il a d'ores et
déjà perdu une part de sa légitimité de
cette autorité morale que vanter à
l'époque madame ex madame dati
non madame dati ex garde des sceaux en
2008 sa nomination suscite en effet de
nombreux doutes et sans aucun doute
d'opposition vous avez rappelé à
plusieurs reprises monsieur le
rapporteur que toutes les autorités
auxquelles va se substituer cette grosse
machine
j'emploie ce terme à dessein ce sont les
vôtres était déjà nommé par l'exécutif
seul mais je encore une fois nous
sommes-nous favorable à leur nomination
par le parlement et je précise je le dis
du point de vue d'un groupe qui est
opposé au présidentialisme depuis fort
longtemps
d'autant plus quand il est monarchique
et qui défend un régime parlementaire
consciente des contradictions à venir
vous avez proposé que le défenseur et
des adjoints soit mais ils seront nommés
par le premier ministre sur proposition
du défenseur nommé par le chef detat
donc exécutive plus exécutif comme
disait notre collègue vous avez été par
deux fois monsieur le rapporteur porteur
d'un amendement destiné à prévoir que
leur nomination serait soumise à l'avis
des commissions permanentes du parlement
est tout à coup en seconde lecture vous
avez aligné votre position sur celle du
gouvernement
au prétexte de la constitution seraient
muette sur un tel avis s'agissant des
nominations par le premier ministre de
fait vous faites leur dit vous fait dire
à l'article 71 1 qui l'interdît l'avis
des commissions sur ces nominations
quant au défenseur des enfants il devra
se contenter d'une dénomination et sera
un adjoint parmi les autres sous
l'autorité comme les autres du défenseur
je doute que cela soit conforme à la
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant ou à la convention européenne
sur l'exercice des droits des enfants
de fait les adjoints n'auront
pratiquement aucun pouvoir et devant se
contenter comme vous l'avez dit d'un
rôle de collaborateur ça a été répété
tout à l'heure on va dire de subordonner
ce sera plus clair
vous avez dit explicitement que si une
manif m6 le rapporteur c'est vous jeunes
site s'ils manifestent leur opposition
ils seront virés
c'est clair donc subordonnés nous avons
pu un moment avoir l'impression que la
commission des lois du sénat après les
avoir créé voulait conforter leur
position c'était être trop confiant
quant au collège vous avait invoqué là
aussi monsieur le ministre l'article 71
1 pour affirmer qu'il ne pourrait avoir
un quelconque pouvoir cet article leur
donnant seulement mission d'assister le
défenseur des droits le texte issu des
travaux de la commission mixte paritaire
prévoit qu'ils seront consultés mais
pour des questions nouvelles caisses
seront les questions nouvelles on verra
dans la pratique et de toute façon leur
avis ne généreront aucun effet
contraignant
la cmp a modifié la désignation des
personnalités qualifiées puisque 3
seront désignés par les présidents de
l'assemblée nationale et 3 par le
président du sénat mais vous avez refusé
que les membres des collèges désignent
eux-mêmes des personnalités qualifiées
comme c'est le cas par exemple à la cnds
la logique est assez compréhensible
le défenseur aura tous les pouvoirs mais
il y en a un qui n'aura pas c'est celui
d'effectuer des visites inopinées c'est
significatif de la logique de ce texte
le défenseur aura toute latitude pour
désigner d'autres adjoints pour d'autres
missions lesquels n'ont lesquelles
celles aujourd'hui assurée par la cnil
par la cad a peut-être aussi plus tard
du contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté en réalité la porte
quand même ouverte dès le début vous
avez voulu nous convaincre que vous
preniez modèle sur les ombres ousmane en
poste dans les pays d'europe venait même
de dire qu'il sera en gros le meilleur
de cela et tout particulièrement
d'ailleurs modèle sur le défenseur du
peuple espagnol
je note qu'ils sont désignés par le
parlement
le défenseur espagnol est d'ailleurs le
haut-commissaire du parlement sans
chambre de saisine par les citoyens ce
sont les administrations les entreprises
publiques les missions de service public
comme votre médiateur ses missions celle
des services publics comme notre
médiateur en outre les communautés
autonomes en leur propre défenseur des
enfants
et n'oublions pas qu'il a été mis en
place dans la période de l'après
franquisme
après des décennies de négation totale
des droits
tout cela fait quand même beaucoup de
différence avec ce que vous proposez
pour le défenseur des droits en france
ce que vous voulez imposer c'est bien
une institution sur la sous la tutelle
et les desiderata du président et public
avec des conditions de nomination des
objectifs évidents concentré dans ce
domaine comme dans d'autres tous les
pouvoirs l'idée avait même été émises
dans le débat au sénat en 2008 que le
défenseur des droits est à arbitrer
entre l'exercice du droit de grève et la
continuité des services publics au nom
de son indépendance je présume
le projet de loi de finances était
silencieux sur les moyens qui lui sont
dévolues n'en savons pas plus depuis
lors nul doute que votre choix de
réduire les dépenses publiques ne paraît
pas étrangère non plus au regroupement
des autorités un choix à géométrie
variable cependant puisqu'il semble que
le gouvernement annonce la création
d'une nouvelle autorité administrative
indépendante pour prévenir les conflits
d'intérêts comprenne qui voudra
nous regrettons que la commission des
lois du sénat se soit finalement dans sa
majorité totalement rallier à la
position du gouvernement
mais c'est vrai que ça avait été décidé
en haut lieu
après la justice et les médias le
président la république veut exercer sa
tutelle sur ce domaine très sensible
qu'est la protection des droits et
libertés
quand on voit les attaques permanentes
contre l'institution judiciaire parce
qu'elle dérange les affichages
sécuritaire il ya tout lieu d'être
inquiet comme si ce que quant à l'avenir
du défenseur des droits
les propos du député et responsable de
l'ump eric ciotti qui s'insurge contre
les pouvoirs du juge de l'application
des peines et propose de confier au
parquet la coordination de l'exécution
des peines donnent des raisons de
s'inquiéter
dans ce contexte vos affirmations sur
l'indépendance des défenseurs
apparaissent quand même assez suspecte
pour toutes ces raisons nous avons voté
contre nous continuerons de le faire
contre le projet de loi organique et
contre le projet de loi sans merci
madame la présidente et le dernier
orateur inscrit
c'est antoine lefèvre
donc monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur cher
doyen gélard
mes chers collègues dernier orateur
inscrit dans cette discussion générale
je ne ferai pas comme d'autres une
discutions de politique générale mais je
placerais mes propos au nom de mon
groupe dans le sillage des conclusions
notre rapporteur qui nous invitaient
adopté ce texte comme il a été beaucoup
question d'oiseaux ce matin je ne vais
pas me parer des plumes du paon en cet
instant mais je tiens à souligner que la
création du défenseur des droits
constitue une étape importante dans le
renforcement de la protection des droits
et libertés dans notre pays
vous l'avez d'ailleurs à juste titre
souligné monsieur le ministre
le défenseur des droits veille au
respect des droits et libertés par les
administrations de l'état les
collectivités territoriales les
établissements publics ainsi que par
tout organisme investi d'une mission de
service public tels énoncés de l'article
71 1 de la constitution qui crée le
défenseur des droits autorités
constitutionnelles et uninominal
il s'agit donc de renforcer
substantiellement les possibilités de
recours non juridictionnel dont
disposent les citoyens pour assurer la
défense de leurs droits et libertés
cette nouvelle institution regroupe cela
a été rappelé les tâches qui incombaient
jusqu'à présent au médiateur de la
république au défenseur des enfants à la
commission nationale de déontologie de
la sécurité et à la haute autorité de
lutte contre les discriminations et pour
l'égalité la halde
l'un des grains l'intégration des
missions de contrôleur général des lieux
de privation de liberté dans celles du
défenseur des droits a été discuté et
finalement supprimée et nous en
satisfaisant pleinement car cette
institution encore récente
un champ d'action véritablement
spécifiques en effet la mission de
contrôleur général et triple s'assurer
que les droits intangibles inhérents la
dignité humaine sont respectés s'assurer
qu'un juste équilibre entre le respect
des droits fondamentaux des personnes
privées de liberté et les considérations
d'ordre public et de sécurité étaient
établis mais aussi et surtout prévenir
toute violation de leurs droits
fondamentaux
par ailleurs des inquiétudes ont été
suscitées en ce qui concerne
l'intégration des fonctions du défenseur
des enfants
cette disposition était maintenue et
ceux ci étaient nécessaires
karl est important de rappeler que le
défenseur des droits disposera
d'absolument tous les pouvoirs de
l'actuelle défenseure des enfants
il pourra alerter sur les cas
individuels ou collectifs proposer des
modifications de la réglementation et
sensibiliser l'opinion
vous l'aurez compris mes chers collègues
nous avons eu à coeur de préserver
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant
concernant la saisine du défenseur des
droits elle pourra être directement
mises en oeuvre par toute personne
physique ou morale qui s'estime lésée
dans ses droits et libertés par le
fonctionnement d'une administration afin
d'accomplir au mieux sa mission le
défenseur des droits sera assisté
d'adjoints dont la désignation ne sera
pas soumise à l'approbation des
commissions parlementaires puisqu'ils
sont les collaborateurs privilégié du
défenseur des droits et non des contre
pouvoirs à celui ci des collèges
compétent en matière de déontologie de
la sécurité en matière de défense et de
promotion des droits de l'enfant ainsi
que dans la lutte contre les
discriminations et pour la promotion de
l'égalité seront institués la
consultation de ces collèges par le
défenseur des droits revêtira un
caractère obligatoire sous réserve des
modalités définies dans le règlement
intérieur
constituant une garantie supplémentaire
dans le bien fondé les décisions que
prendra le défenseur des droits dans ces
matières si spécifique la composition de
ces trois collèges a suscité de nombreux
débats
certains n'ont appelé et nous
satisfaisons de l' équilibre retrouvé
par les rapporteurs quant à la place de
chacune des personnalités qualifiées
j'en finirai en abordant les modalités
d'intervention du défenseur des droits
dont je tiens à rappeler le rôle
historique que nous lui conférons
aujourd'hui le défenseur des droits aura
l'obligation de motiver ses décisions de
ne pas donner suite aux saisines il
s'agit d'un principe important que nous
souhaitons garantir à nos concitoyens
enfin le défenseur des droits ne pourra
déposé deux requêtes constituant une
action collective devant le juge
administratif la possibilité de
l'inscription dans notre droit d'une
telle innovation constitue certes une
idée intéressante mais devra faire
l'objet d'une réflexion approfondie par
le parlement avant d'être inscrite dans
une loi je tiens à remercier à nouveau
le rapporteur pour la qualité de son
travail ainsi que les membres de la
commission des lois sous la houlette de
son président qui ont su trouver un
juste équilibre pour la création de
cette nouvelle institution
mais chaque oeil
ces textes constituant une étape
importante dans le renforcement de la
protection des droits et libertés dans
notre pays et donc c'est pour cette
raison que l'ensemble du groupe ump
votera avec conviction je vous remercie
merci antoine lefèvre monsieur le
président de la commission des lois jean
jacques hyest président c'est que le le
sénat s'était beaucoup investi dans la
création du défenseur des droits
car si vous rappeler les étapes
l'article 71 1 qui nous est arrivé avec
un défenseur d'ailleurs des citoyens et
on a dit mais c'est pas d'abord l'époque
des citoyens les enfants notamment et
donc nous avions bien pensé que et puis
les tous des étrangers qui sont sur
notre territoire ils sont des droits et
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a trouvé
défenseur des droits à moi ce que je
trouve paradoxal je le dis c'est qu'un
certain nombre de nos collègues donne
toutes les vertus aux institutions qui
existent
très bien mais il n'y avait pas de
nominations avec le la consultation du
parlement
il n'y avait pas ils ont été nommés par
qui d'ailleurs pas souvent par le
pouvoir exécutif que certains ont
combattu et ils ont révélé leur grande
autonomie je remercie jacques mézard
d'ailleurs d'avoir rappelé ce que nous
on s'en souvient bien qu est ce qu a
fait grandir médiateur
tous les présidents mais tout le monde
se souvient de jacques pelletier et id
et et de monsieur delevoye
c'est eux qui ont donné vraiment au
médiateur toute l'ampleur il ya eu
bernard stasi aussi mais toute l'ampleur
de 2 2 lors de leur mission alors bob il
ya une autre chose qui me paraît
paradoxal c'est qu'on divise
complètement ce qui est médiation et
contrôle des droits bas le défenseur des
enfants fait de la médiation fait de la
médiation
aujourd'hui pas seulement et la halde
aussi c'est une des missions qu'on leur
a donné
non je crois que c'est tout ça c'est pas
c'est pas très par contre ce qui me
paraît fondamental c'est que à partir du
moment où il ya un défenseur des droits
qui est
tu es de pouvoirs exceptionnels ça n'est
plus le médiateur ne dit pas on a
fusionné le médiateur et les autres on a
créé vraiment une nouvelle institution
qui va pouvoir défendre les droits et il
était naturel moi je le dis parce que
c'est que tout ce qui concerne la
défense des droits devraient être
regroupées dans une même institution
et comme l'a dit très bien jacques
mézard on peut pas défendre les droits
d'un côté et qui est des institutions
concurrentes tout doit être défense des
droits et c'est pourquoi je me semble
que c'est complètement équilibré alors
dernier point je pense que effectivement
on verra bien que cette institution va
se renforcer vous ayez des institutions
qui ont été critiqués même je ne suis
pas sûr que le médiateur était bien
apprécié quand il a été créé c'était une
volonté d'ailleurs notamment au sénat et
la réticence quand même que le médiateur
puisse être saisi directement
aujourd'hui encore en théorie le
médiateur il peut être saisi par
l'intermédiaire de parlementaires il en
est de même de la scène death
aujourd'hui c'est tout le monde qui pour
aller saisir directement eh bien je
pense que c'est un sacré renforcement
des droits des citoyens comme l'est bien
entendu la question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité je crois que ces deux
éléments qui sont tout à fait important
pour faire évoluer notre société par une
meilleure défense des droits alors
anecdotiquement en ce qui concerne les
nominations
franchement et moi je vous le dit depuis
le départ les 3/5 cepal c'est pas le
problème
parce que ça veut dire c'est tellement
consensuel qu'on va finir par nommer des
personnalités qui n'est pas forcément la
plus grande autorité par contre
il suffit d'une majorité car on sait
bien que si on nous présente pour tous
ces postes qui sont nommés pas or en
vertu de l'article 13 des personnalités
qui nous conviennent pas la majorité
simple suffit ils ne seront jamais nommé
et je crois que ça un dispositif
préventif qui est largement suffisant et
je suis convaincu que comme on l'a fait
pour le contrôleur général des lieux
privatifs de liberté
on ne peut que se féliciter de l'action
de monsieur delarue
si nous avons demain quelqu'un de cette
qualité comme défenseur des droits je
peux vous assurer que ça serait une
institution au service de nos
concitoyens
merci jean jacques hyest monsieur le
ministre michel mercier nous avez la
parole monsieur le garde des sceaux
merci beaucoup monsieur le premier juste
quelques mots je devrais répondre très
brièvement à l'ensemble des orateurs je
veux remercier monsieur le faire pour
l'analyse complète et qu'il a fait du
texte est excellente et tout à fait
d'ailleurs monsieur courtois et arrive à
ce moment là parce qu'ils avaient envie
de l'écouter on est heureux de voir
ainsi porter les choses je voudrais
aussi remercier monsieur lézard qui dans
la première partie de son intervention a
su donner une définition qui est
probablement la meilleure de toutes
du défenseur des droits et je le
remercie de cette a peur qu'il a bien
voulu faire la discussion et au texte
très attendu
on est moins d'accord avec lui sur les
autres parties de son intervention
parce que il a repris des choses qui
honnêtement ne peuvent pas emporté
l'adhésion
alors pour les autres acteurs me susurre
m'dame de présidente borvo cohen seat
et il y a plusieurs critiques qui ont
été faites qui ne me semble pas
d'ailleurs complètement devoir remporter
l'adhésion
parce qu'elle ne semble pas tout à fait
fondée la première critique qui a été
fait c'est celle d'hier
la nomination la domination sera une
sorte de péché originel
et bien moi je dois dire que dans ce cas
vous en avez fait pas mal de péché
originel et que depuis qu'il ya des
autorités administratives indépendantes
elles sont nommés par le président de la
république et qu'on le veuille ou non et
je comprends bien que vous ne vouliez
pas le reconnaître des ja pas voter la
réforme de la constitution vous trouvez
un peu gêné aux entournures elle pas
vouloir reconnaître que la consultation
même du parlement est une limitation
importante à l'exercice du pouvoir de
nomination du président de la république
quel qu'il soit
le président de la république il
proposera au parlement
quelqu'un qui peut recevoir une majorité
et c'est pas le problème et je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec le président de la
commission des lois
c'est pas le problème des trois
cinquièmes ou pas trois cinquièmes c'est
le problème d'avoir un vote positif qui
cote
on ne peut pas aller au delà j'ajoute
que ce qui fait l'indépendance dans
notre droit public républicain c'est pas
la condition de la domination seul fait
qu'on ne peut pas être renommé et le
mandat il est unique et on ne peut pas
faire un second mandat
c'est cela qui forment dans notre droit
public républicain
l'indépendance c'est vrai pour les
membres du conseil constitutionnel c'est
vrai pour tous les membres des autorités
administratives indépendantes et il y à
là le fondement même de l'indépendance
de l'autorité
après chaque personne nommée lorsqu'il
est investie du pouvoir qui lui est
donnée les exprime ses compétences et
donne corps à l'institution monsieur sur
un lundi quand même quelque chose qui va
pas du tout c'est que s'ils collège
n'est pas suivi par le défenseur des
droits bien il faut que
défenseur des droits explique pourquoi
il ne suit pas l'avis du collège alors
ça honnêtement il faut pas comment ça
pourrait fonctionner et c'est comme si
on disait aux gouvernements quels qu'ils
soient
lorsqu'il suit pas l'avis du conseil
d'état expliqué pourquoi vous suivez pas
l'avis du conseil d'état
oui allemand suit pas l'avis du conseil
d'état parce qu'ils ne le suis pas et
après je rappelle qu est ce qui est
important c'est que le défenseur après
les travaux de la commission mixte
paritaire doit cet article 21 si je me
souviens bien où va du texte doit
motiver sa décision vis-à-vis du
demandeur et ça c'est important et c'est
pas qu'ils modifient kid motive sa
décision par rapport à la vie du collège
et qui n'est pas public
mais est ce qui est important c'est
qu'il motive sa décision par rapport à
la demande qui lui est faite
et puis troisième critique qui a été
fait notamment par madame la présidente
borvo cohen-séat cessé de dire y aura
moins de pouvoirs
c'est bien sûr complètement fou et je
pense que son exemple
c'est celui des visites sur place
aujourd'hui le texte est clair c'est
l'article 18 2 qui prévoit expressément
ce qui dépasse et celui là le voilà le
défenseur des droits peut procéder à des
vérifications sur place dans le quadiste
ratifie privée des personnes mises en
cause des vérifications sur place dans
des lieux le coût moyen de transport
accessible au public qu'aux
professionnels et il n'a pas besoin de
demander d'autorisation il décide
lui-même et d'y aller et c'est un
changement complet
aujourd'hui la haute autorité la halde
peut après avis adressé aux personnes
intéressées et avec leur accord
le chargé en incluant ses membres de
procéder à des vérifications sur place
désormais le défenseur des droits
proprio mots tu pourras 2 lui même
procédé à des visites sur place vérifier
sur place
il entendra à vérifier c'est un vrai
progrès et puis enfin et la
présidentielle a rappelé mais c'est
fondamental c'est que chaque citoyen
pourra saisir le défenseur des droits et
je me leur dire parce que on oublie trop
souvent et cette majorité a voté deux
dispositions importantes 3 qui donne aux
citoyens un accès direct à la défense
des droits c'est la qpc
mais je reviendrai pour conclure parce
qu'un borvo usa quand même failli
démonstration qui est assez affriolantes
de ce que c'est que la défense des
droits à travers la qpc
mais c'est chaque citoyen peut désormais
saisir le conseil constitutionnel
chaque citoyen peut désormais saisir
conseil supérieur de la magistrature de
ben comment jugerait ainsi d'un
magistrat et il y a déjà beaucoup de
citoyens qui ont saisi le csm et chaque
citoyen pourra désormais saisir le
défenseur des droits st la saisine
directe par les citoyens et des
autorités administratives indépendantes
c'est un vrai progrès alors et je vais
te les terminerait pas la recette
président madame la présidente boc
retraite dit est la qpc
c'est vraiment pas bien parce que des
fois ça donne des résultats qui sont pas
ceux qu'on voudrait bien c'est le propre
c'est le propre de toute mesure qui vise
à défendre les droits et la liberté
c'est pas fait pour plaire et notamment
c'est pas fait pour plaire à ceux qui
exercent le pouvoir qu'il soit exécutif
ou législatif mais c'est fait pour
assurer la prééminence du droit et j'ose
dire sans aucun problème que ce texte
nous aidera à assurer dans notre pays et
la prééminence du droit
si monsieur le ministre
alors sur les deux textes je ne suis
saisi d'aucun amendements nous allons
passer au vote sur le projet de loi
organique conformément à l'article 42
alinéa 12 du règlement
je vais mettre aux voix l'ensemble du
projet de loi organique dans la
rédaction résultant du texte proposé par
la commission mixte paritaire et je vais
donner la parole à alain anziani pour
explication de vote
oui juste juste quelques mots monsieur
monsieur le président en quelques mots à
la fin de ces débats pour vous dire que
nous ne voyons toujours pas quel est le
motif véritable de la création de ce
défenseur des droits on sait que c'est
une création constitutionnel donc on va
pas revenir sur ces débats mais nous
aurions espéré que notre discussion face
surgir quelques lumières
est-ce que ce défenseur des droits est
motivée par le fait que les autorités
administratives indépendantes qu'il va
remplacer ne fonctionnait pas nous
n'avons absolument pas eu la preuve ou
même moindre élément est bien au
contraire on vient encore de nous dire
qu'elle fonctionnait et que celle qui
est à échapper presque par miracle
c'était le contrôleur général des lieux
de privation était une institution
formidable avec un homme remarquable à
sa tête
donc on ne sait pas et on a vu
d'ailleurs dans le débat de cette
semaine sur la garde à vue tout le rôle
de la commission nationale de
déontologie de la sécurité avec de
multiples témoignages
comme quoi cette institution évidemment
était sans doute irremplaçable et nous
risquons de la regrettée dans les années
qui viennent donc on ne sait pas quel
est ce motif est ce que c'est un motif
d'économie on n'en parle même plus plus
personne d'ailleurs de soutien que le
défenseur des droits va faire davantage
d'économies on voit pas effectivement
comment une structure unique et
hiérarchique polymorphe permettra de
faire des économies là où des structures
des instances de mission sont sans doute
avec leur souplesse beaucoup plus
réactive et sans doute
génératrice de moins en moins de coups
alors j'ai entendu tout à l'heure des
arguments l'argument monsieur le garde
des sceaux qui avait que beaucoup de
forces a affirmé tout à l'heure que nous
allons disposer avec le défenseur des
droits d'un ombudsman qui serait le plus
puissant d'europe sauf que vous éludez
ce débat que nous avons été quelques-uns
constamment à animer est-ce que l'on
peut être puissant lorsque dans sa
nomination cette puissance dépend de la
puissance de l'exécutif
c'est havas ce débat va sts débat et je
voudrais là aussi se féliciter notre
rapporteur qui tout à l'heure du haut de
la tribune nous disait il faudra trouver
l'oiseau rare
ça va pas être facile et trouver les
oiseaux race est l'illustration de ce
que je viens de dire si vous nommer
madame de panafieu bas on voit bien que
l'indépendance risque de permettre
d'être plus limitée elle sera là par la
grâce du pouvoir exécutif est parce qu
il lui aura fallu lui trouver un lot de
consolation
évidemment son indépendance sera plus
limitée que si monsieur delarue était
nommé donc tout dépend de la personne
qui va être nommé mais si tout dépend de
la personne qui va être nommé tout
dépend de la personne qui nomme et nous
savons que ce qu'ils nomment c'est le
pouvoir exécutif qui va nommer son
propre contrôleur est bien évidemment là
il ya sans doute avis dans cette
institution
j'ai entendu la réflexion de monsieur le
président de la commission des lois et
messieurs présent la commission des lois
nous disaient oui mais avant c'était pas
mieux
d'accord mais si après c'est toujours
pareil à quoi tout cela at il servi on
ne voit pas du tout les progrès qu'ils
auront été effectués alors je terminerai
en rappelant quand même une phrase que
j'aime beaucoup qui est de montesquieu
et montesquieu
disait très souvent que il fallait
toucher la loi que d'une main tremblante
eh bien on va vous permettra de garder
ceux de dire que vous voulez toucher
d'un revers de la main
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
voterons contre ce texte bien je n'ai
plus d'autres demandes d'explications de
vote plus de demandes de prise de parole
jeu mais se voit l'ensemble du projet de
loi organique dans la rédaction
résultant du texte proposé par la
commission mixte paritaire en
application de l'article 59 du règlement
le scrutin public et de droit
il va être procédé dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement
ceux qui souhaitent voter pour un
bulletin blanc contre un bulletin bleu
et l'abstention à bulletin rouge le
scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants est le scrutin est ouvert
alors
plus personne ne demande à voter eh bien
j invite le scrutin est clos et j'invite
mesdames et messieurs les secrétaires a
procédé au dépouillement du scrutin
bah
non
ce
mais
alors résultats du scrutin numéro 173
sur l'ensemble du projet de loi
organique relatif au défenseur des
droits dans la rédaction proposée par la
commission mixte paritaire nombre de
votants 338 nombre de suffrages exprimés
323 majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés
162 pour l'adoption 185 contre 138
le sénat a adopté nous quittons
l'hémicycle du sénat merci à vous
d'avoir suivi cette séance si vous
souhaitez la revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
à suivre cet après midi à partir de 15h
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement présenté par perrine
tarneaud merci de votre fidélité très
belle journée à tous